no
i knew it yeah
ah
oh like it's hitting me more
i'm a little nervous my stomach is
fickle so we'll see how this goes could
end badly i'm excited to have americans
try this food i think it's an acquired
taste and some of the things are like
very different i actually don't like
some of the dishes but i'm excited to
see what the people think divide
like two shapes divide cushion
it looks kind of like if you like deep
fried a mouse it's basically just
chicken wrapped in like
breading and there's just a chunk of
butter inside and they sort of wrap it
around the bone so it's like an empty
bone and they wrap it this was my
favorite favorite thing as a kid i don't
know how to best tackle this you just
cut it down the middle maybe
oh look at the grease oh my gosh oh this
is a good one it literally just spills
out oh my god look at this you can see
it
oh my gosh there is so much butter in
there oh here all right so
nostrovia it means to health
it's like chicken noodle soup inside a
chicken tastes pretty standard like
yeah i'd eat it for lunch i guess
i want another piece me too that was
amazing we stand i like the crust it
takes a lot to chew it though that's
good because there's the holidays
you don't have to talk about politics or
family you can just chew this a lot
[Music]
this doesn't look as good here we have
alivia which is the most probably
traditional salad you can think of
what's inside so usually it's carrots
potatoes green peas
mayonnaise maybe like pickles pickles
and you can have like chicken or ham and
like sometimes it's a lot of mayonnaise
depends on how you like it this one
doesn't have too much mayonnaise um i
love this salad this throat
there's a lot of different flavors that
i can't really quite get a read on
it's
delicious there any fish in here is this
egg no this is is this egg potato salad
is this fish potato salad it's not bad
it tastes like potato salad
but there's some extra here you want any
more
there's nothing left
it looks like cake but i know it's not
it's like a lot of different shades of
pink
which i don't really know how that works
which is
herring under a coat
so on top you have sliced eggs
cheese
a layer of mayonnaise then you have
beets
potatoes then you have
herring pickled herring pickled herring
and then more potatoes ah yeah i think
for this one we just dive in nervous i'm
like sweating
no
i knew it ah
it doesn't taste bad
there's just
it does oh like it's hitting me more
it's like fish mayonnaise you know how
willy wonka crafted like
a candy that was like dinner in your
mouth and it went through courses yeah i
feel like this is the worst dinner you
could possibly have because at first it
starts out and you're like oh you just
ate a bunch of mayonnaise and then you
start tasting like pickly stuff and then
there's just this nasty aftertaste in
the back of your mouth it's a hard pass
for me yeah no please sorry thank you i
don't want to see it anymore
is it literally just a tomato we have
the pickled tomato russians pickle
everything you can have like pickled
watermelon apples apples they pickle
apples honey
the whole thing
is that not how you eat it
what i love this is this like a pickled
tomato
i don't trust that i think you'll just
witness me discovering my new favorite
snack
as traditional as you can get uh white
bread with some butter and some ira
which is
baby eggs fish eggs yeah they would go
to the movies or something and and in
the soviet union when they would go out
they would just get like some bread with
like that was just like the snack that
you would munch on all the time when i
went to the beach with my grandparents
it was a boiled egg cucumbers and that
ripped them like really yeah what
happens when they get hot
oh that's
growing up rushing
do you like you cry i do it's a it's you
have to be in the mood for it i i enjoy
personally not to be bougie yeah black
caviar it's not as fishy it's just a lot
saltier than typical i feel like i need
to drink a gallon of water with every
bite i take i don't hate it
but i don't think i'd actively be like
oh i want this egg bread
like yo y'all want to meet up and get
egg bread
they're sardines
sardines on white bread butter we're
simple people i think i used to love
these as a kid but i have not had them
in years they're golden sardines are
sardines so these aren't gold are they
don't they look like covered in gold
they do look kind of golden do they
always look golden i swear to god
if these are gold-plated sardines you
are wasting your money
this is delicious literally it's like
it's a nice smoked like salty fish it
doesn't taste like caviar it doesn't
taste like
um the pickled herring it's not fishy
it's more like
oily and and salty
it tastes like a small like just little
cooked fish i'm gonna finish this whole
piece of toast this is great
it looks
like cake smells it doesn't like fish no
smell this is your favorite cake right
this is called napoleon the taste i like
creamy stuff like lobster tails and all
that stuff the reason i really like this
cake is because it's not too sweet this
feels like very light very flaky um and
just like you can eat a lot of it
without getting sick
that's good that's good cake
is it cake is it a pastry is this fish
potato salad this is more like bread so
that's basically like the most iconic
things that you're gonna see at every
table you know maybe i just won't go to
that many soviet holiday parties herring
under the coat it's cancelled pickled
tomatoes you got you got renewed for
another season at home if you're bored
go to a russian supermarket near you buy
some weird or interesting looking stuff
try it let us know if you liked it in
the comments below